northwestern state pen oh yeah you know
everybody's talking about them in the
offseason here we'll certainly one of
the marquee programs out there now this
is you know Baylor doing what Baylor
does which is scheduled horribly in the
non-conference and it's really just a
chance to see what Baylor looks like
what Jim Grobe is the coach I don't even
know where they're going to turn his
headset on because his coaching style is
so different than art brows and they
kept all the old staff and I got players
that fit what the old staff does I think
he's like the ultimate figurehead right
now but we had Jimbo Fisher on at the
top of the hour they start out with ole
miss you got Alabama USC why is it that
some coaches programs are starting out
with a tough opponent and Baylor
starting out with Northwestern State
yeah Baylor hasn't gotten the memo that
they're good yet you know and that you
need to start scheduling that way they
should have because that's what kept
them out of the college football playoff
the first year was weak scheduling and I
think it's great that we have so many
good opening season games this is the
best opening weekend I can ever remember
because people have realized a we can
play a neutral site game and make money
on it and being we can help our strength
of schedule by playing somebody who's
good and strength of schedule at least
ostensibly means more nowadays with
playoff with what's happening with Colin
Kaepernick I wondered what other players
would other teammates players around the
NFL follow suit what about college
football do you think we would see any
sort of protest in line with Colin
Kaepernick this season I think it's less
likely um you know it certainly I don't
think you would see like a solitary guy
or you know one or two I know yet he had
a couple guys with him last night but
you know they've got less power in all
of this maybe if it was a whole team
thing like the Missouri situation where
everybody got together and said this is
what we're going to do and guess what
coaches you're going to go along with us
because otherwise you don't have a team
but in general I think they would
the potential for greater backlash
especially if it's one or two guys and
they're in a less powerful position most
important game of the week is where I
kind of think sunday and i think i think
we're Charlie Strong I've in Texas
against Notre Dame because they cannot
start like they did last year and not
have everybody just completely get off
the bandwagon for him they've got they
got to play well if not when they've got
to move the football they've got to show
something on offense and then actually
you know appear that they can they can
throw the football or else people will
be starting to say when we bring in Tom
Herman I mean they won't give unmeaning
Marie on Charlie Strong as this season
doesn't start well what did Tennessee
tell you last night who is it over rated
everyone's I told me that that was the
maybe they were very lucky to win an
Appalachian State say a good smaller
program and they you know they played
their guts out but I thought Appalachian
State coaches as much anybody gave that
came away by being too conservative at
the end of my bungling the clock and so
I mean I Tennessee is really lucky to
get out of there with a win they got to
be coming out saying holy cow we we
can't take this level to play into the
SEC or we're doomed sneaky team you like
this year um you know I boy babe I'm not
sure how sneaky they are I go back to
Boise State you know which I've always
been a matter of that program but I
think they can go 12 and 0 13 a no-win
that mountain west and be sitting there
saying hey you know why not us in the
playoff their schedule is is pretty easy
they've got lose washington state which
is not a bad opponent but otherwise I
think that they've got a chance to reel
off a ton of wins they brought it back a
lot of experience from last year's team
that was good they should I think once
again be that program they wash you
stayed in that oregon state of their two
non-conference games of note i wouldn't
be shocked if they're undefeated who is
less likely to duplicate or even come
close to their numbers from last season
Christian McCaffrey
Leonard fournette or deshaun Watson who
I mean Christian mccaffrey's numbers are
so big first of all they got to play 14
games with the with the conference
championship game I mean if they get in
the playoff may be good but I mean that
was unbelievable productivity broke
Barry Sanders single-season all-purpose
yardage record that's hard to do again
if he stays healthy he'll have a chance
I mean he's he's a real deal as a player
ask I think I was defensive players are
still in therapy from the Rose Bowl
after what he said to them but just I
mean that's a lot to ask for a guy that
six foot two hundred that stay healthy
and carry the ball that many times in
that many ways you see you know a game
that i think is sneaky great is UCLA
texas A&M yeah it is hey if i could have
worked out if i had the Dan Patrick swag
copter I could have tried to go to
Houston Oklahoma noon leave early go
catch the second half of in college
station of UCLA Texas A&M and then come
to Dallas it would have been the perfect
thing enjoy your weekend and it's always
great to talk to you I'm glad you're on
the road for a change pat thank you very
much time to make it brown had 40 from
yahoo sports the 40-yard dash on yahoo
sports the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience